I don't believe that women should have
to suffer in silence and i would say 99
percent of all of our cases no one has
ever heard of no one ever will hear of
they will not be discussed publicly
unless it until they end up in a court
of law but most are settled
confidentially so you'll never hear
about them yes they will have to
describe what happened to them to the
opposing party and in a court of law if
it gets the trial which most cases won't
but some decide to speak out publicly
and speaking out publicly helps them to
be empowered actually in many cases and
also it helps to inspire other women to
know that they can stand up and fight
back that they don't have to be
victimized if they are victimized that
they can move on to the next stage which
is to become a survivor and then finally
to the next stage which is to be a
fighter for change so they can evolve
and and make others accountable for the
wrongs that have been inflicted upon
them it's about accountability it's
about transparency and it's about change
it's about justice most of all
it really depends on the case I
sometimes it's like an educational
moment or opportunity and sometimes it
strategic sometimes it's both for
example we had a case years ago of AIDS
discrimination Our client went Paul
jasperson went to Jessica's nail salon
to get a pedicure he made an appointment
then they heard that he had AIDS and
they called and canceled it or that he
was hiv-positive at the time they
canceled it and we fought them for 16
years we said that's discrimination and
my client spoke out and said I'm not
going to take this type of
discrimination it's wrong and it's also
illegal and by doing so he let other
businesses know that people who are
hiv-positive need to be treated with
respect and dignity and have a right to
enjoy their rights to be free of
discrimination under the law that sends
a message not only to Jessica's nail
salon but to other businesses as well
that you better watch yourself that you
might find yourself on the wrong end of
a lawsuit and being spoken out publicly
if you make the big mistake of
discriminating so it's a teaching moment
and I know that Paul was very happy that
he did that he was never sorry that he
did that and even though we passed away
at some point we continued the battle
even after his death it's a case by case
analysis of what we're trying to
accomplish in the case and how best to
accomplish it there's no one general
rule one size fits all it really depends
on the case as I said most of the time
you'll never hear about most of my cases
and every once in a while for example
I'll get a call from the LA Times or
someone else saying we just found out
that you filed this case nobody told us
and and they just find it but most of
the time they will never know what would
that's the way it should be because what
is best for the client is what's most
important